yeah so I think unless you teach
students hold their hands and take them
that path which is not what's done in
the school the public school system
doesn't do that so they have very
standards they have an exams to pass so
most of the teachers are actually
teaching them based on those exams
because they're you know kind of they
themselves are judged by how their
students do on the standardized exam and
so as a result of real learning is lost
so with ck-12 from very early on we had
this theory that we are going to teach
you from so if you look at what we call
simulations we kind of take the stand
that we are going to talk about say how
does a plane stay afloat raining and so
readable examples yeah real-world
applications of that and so if you start
talking to them about trust thrust and
you talk about free diagram free you
know energy diagram they lost but what
if you were to able be able to relate
this with this question and think about
what are the sub components of this
question and then be able to show them
and let them play with it
very often these are taught as yes
that's right so we do that good
chemistry we do that with physics right
now I'd love to create you know I'd love
to create some partnership to do that
with biology and finish all these and
kind of you might have some ideas for
you yes I'd love to do that because you
know we can only go at the we are only
30 people in palo alto and then another
you know 15 20 people in india yet we're
doing all this ourselves and so and
teachers are submitting content as a
contract to you but those are those are
mostly written things this other stuff
we do ourselves video the the
simulations and the ability to interact
the staff the adaptive system the
intelligence system was a ice yes all
that we're doing in-house by ourselves
and the teachers of submitting text
learning yes they're doing the actual
content on you know the like the Flex
book which is a customizable textbook
and yes so they are doing that part of
it and so we created about 250 flex
books for all k12 today we have over
200,000 flex books customized by
teachers and schools and districts and
they're all free there so another good
thing about all this you know
customization is not just
personalization but the ability to hold
institutional memory in one place like
the teacher I was talking about earlier
now foundation kind of doesn't yeah all
right so she passed away but all the
memory she had about stuff went with her
right
so it's institutions every year can
figure out what worked today this year
and you iterate on it next year
that you're constantly improving by
learning learn by doing yeah right so
that's the that's the power of the
system that's the power of technology
technology by itself is just just a tool
it's like a hammer I mean a hammer and a
nail and melt and until there's a human
being doing something with it
it's of no value so one thing that we
did from the beginning was not only just
create the technology we actually create
the payload to go with it and so that
you know isn't what's not what most
EdTech companies are doing they they are
looking for content because they didn't
build it and so you know we are where we
are
you